juli
[Musik]
hallo leute ich zitiere mal waren und
wir kommen zum zehnten sommerloch nach
drei jahren zehn sommerloch löcher los
los los vanessa ich muss ehrlich sagen
dass ich dachte dass ich vielleicht
irgendwann special machte für die zehnte
folge aber dann ist mir aufgefallen ist
ist schon special genug bin ja wann das
er macht ihr selbst komplimente aber
nicht lang schnacken kopp in nacken ich
erzähle euch jetzt was am wochenende
gegen letzten sonntag am 24.9 habe ich
mich zusammengerissen und angefangen
mein arbeitszimmer einzurichten und ich
bin wirklich überfragt wenn es darum
geht es für möglich da rein stelle
möchte ich schränke landhausdielen
möchte ich so coole spinnt schränke oder
soll ich die sachen alle im büro stil
einrichten und dann war ich nach langer
zeit freitag mal wieder an einer bar und
da haben wir die kamera mitgenommen und
da sind wunderbare bilder entstanden
wow wir haben die anderen gäste
überhaupt nicht damit genervt haben wir
glaube ich wirklich nicht mal die hälfte
der leute so betrunken war dass sie gar
nichts mitbekommen hat ja und dann war
ich noch sonntag wählen weil die
bundestagswahl war das egal was absolut
nicht egal es ist mein sommer hat man
jetzt nicht gerade sommer sah gefällt
mir auf dass wir seit dem 22
herbst hierfür dem zwanzigsten herbst an
wie herbst ja irgendeine krankheit wo
die leute reden es tut mir leid es ist
herbst und damit das letzte sommerloch
es tut mir leid
entschuldige ich mich bei euch
wenigstens krieg mir noch im sommerloch
schwert euch nicht und schaut bei dazu
es los mit mir ich habe keine toten
[Musik]
macht mich ein bisschen kritik
vielleicht liegt es auch einfach nur den
wahlergebnissen ich sehe gerade meine
notizen dass wir bei im sommer hack wann
mein sommer hat passt super zum wechsel
von sommer- auf herbst denn ich habe
eine neue entdeckung gemacht klamotten
wechseln will have you been all my life
das prinzip ist ganz einfach ihr nehmt
euch einen beutel legte klamotten rein
und saugt mit einem staubsauger die luft
raus und die ganzen klamotten werden zu
einem dünnen plastikding was nicht so
viel platz wegnimmt weil es ja dünne und
wenn ihr schlau sein dann liegen da drin
eure winter jacken und pullis und herbst
sachen die ihr jetzt alle raus holen
könnt klamotten wechseln meine erste
wahl wenn es ums platz bahn geht
geschichten aus der youtube will
ich bin habe ich nicht mehr mit respekt
sondern habe ein video von dem berge
seen auf seinem kanal grünberg und zwar
hat er seine youtube einnahmen
offengelegt krass oder
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
echt froh bin dass es endlich mal jemand
macht bzw jemand darüber spricht er so
viel reichweite hat wie julien bärin
mich nervt es schon tierisch wenn mir
leute unterstellen dass ich so super
viel kohle habe ich hätte gerne so super
viel kohle aber habe ich einfach nicht
dass man selbst bei einem julien bemerkt
dass die youtube einnahmen nicht
ausreichen um alles zu bezahlen
zeig doch mal wieder dass ideen
verdammten adblocker ausmachen soll wenn
ihr youtube videos schaue also wenn ihr
euch fragt was man mit youtube wirklich
so verdient hat schaut euch mal das
video von julian beckmann erklärt ist
ganz cool wenn ihr es nicht eh schon
gesehen habt wie ist das thema kommen
wir jetzt meinem lieblings sei mein
lieblingssong zurzeit ist 1800 273 8 255
von dem künstler logik dieser song ist
zu einem sehr schön und hat eine gute
messe beziehungsweise hat es ein
bisschen gedauert bis ich gecheckt hat
dass das eine telefonnummer ist und dann
habe ich gecheckt dass die selbstmord
telefonnummer notfallzentrale in den usa
also wenn du selbstmordgedanken hast
rufst du diese nummer an und dann wird
dir geholfen und dieser song handelt
auch so von selbstmord bzw
dass man nicht mehr am leben sein möchte
und am ende ist dann doch alles positive
man möchte wieder am leben sein und das
ist eine gute messe
[Musik]
als michaela geradezu schaut ja ich
komme gerade auf den geschmack ist ihr
nicht verstehen ist ein ding zwischen
mir und mirela ich wollte nur eine
kleine botschaft hier sind hey ich bin
dein größter fan kommen wir jetzt meinen
favoriten mein erster favorit heute ist
etwas was sich auf vegas kanal zum
ersten mal gesehen habe und zwar protein
pulver schrägstrich mahlzeit alternative
das ist so ein pulver was nach vanille
riecht und damit kannst du eine mahlzeit
ersetzen und bevor jetzt die ersten los
schreiben ja eine ausgewogene ernährung
ist sehr sehr wichtig was ich an diesem
pulver markt ist dass es eine mahlzeit
ersetzen kann muss es nicht aber von den
mehrwerten her kann es das tun und es
gibt jetzt bei diesem pulver nicht darum
abzunehmen dann eher dass ich so eine
notfall lösung am stater wenn du morgens
mal keine zeit hast wenn du mittagsmahl
keine zeit hast wenn du arm bist einfach
mal eine mahlzeit aus lassen willst weil
du vielleicht aber auch schon genug
pizza und sonst was am tag gefressen
hass und einfach mal ein paar vitamine
brauchst mein stoffwechsel hilft das
ganz gut wenn ich das mal trinken weil
ich merke dass ich irgendwie wacher und
ein bisschen aktiver bin und mich nicht
so schlapp fühle ist natürlich von
person zu person anders das verstehe ich
es auch ein komisches thema über so
nahrungsergänzung und sowas zu sprechen
weil das natürlich viele junge leute da
draußen gibt die sehr damit zu kämpfen
haben die im übergewicht klar zu kommen
bzw deswegen gemobbt werden und deswegen
total durchdrehen weil wie paar kilos zu
viel wiegen oder eigentlich nicht aber
andere leute das so sagen ist auch
während der entwicklung des körpers
super wichtig dass du alles zu dir
nimmst du nicht hunger ist dass du nicht
irgendwas die verbietet ist weil du
glaubst dass du zu dick ist das ist
falsch ich hab selber ganz lange damit
zu kämpfen gehabt dass ich mich zu dick
gefühlt habe obwohl ich das nicht
wirklich war und mich immer fertig
gemacht habe es gebe jetzt nur darum
eine nahrung zu haben falls ich mal gar
keine zeit habe eigentlich nahrung zu
mir zu nehmen sondern es geht es nicht
ums abnehmen wo ist das ein komisches
thema ich habe das gefühl umso mehr ich
rede dass ich mich umso mehr um kopf und
kragen reden obwohl ich das gar nicht
muss oder mache ihr wisst was ich meine
keiner von euch soll abnehmen wenn ihr
das wollt dann tut es aber stresst euch
nicht alles gut aber über dieses ganze
gesundheitsthemen so wollte ich schon
immer mal ein video machen weil ich da
ganz viel zu in den letzten jahren
gelernt habe und die erfahrungen gerne
mit euch teilen würde deswegen schreibt
man die kommentare wenn ihr euch
wirklich da
informieren wollen bzw wenn ich mal für
meine erfahrungen erzählen soll
berichten soll dann schreibt man jetzt
geht es weiter
die großen parteien cdu und spd haben
für ihre verhältnisse verpackt und die
afg hat fast 13 prozent bekommen dann
wisst ihr was ich habe auf den social
media plattform instagram und twitter
schon genug darüber gesprochen wie ich
dieses wahlergebnis denn so finde
und jetzt komme ich mit einer wirklichen
alternative für deutschland wir nehmen
die afb villa und schieben sie alle nach
sachs ich weise problem dabei ist dass
in sachsen auch ganz viele menschen
leben die nicht die afg gewählt habe die
nehmen wir dann alle in dem ohne sachsen
deutschland auf und um sachsen bauen wir
eine mauer
dann können alle fdp-wähler fröhlich
untereinander leben ohne flüchtlinge
ohne ausländer mehr da ist nicht super
ich meine es wäre noch dann alle
zufrieden oder nicht hast du mir
wirklich leid für die leute die dann in
sachsen die man dann umziehen müssen
aber im endeffekt das ist eine
win-win-situation und bitte tut mir den
gefallen und von unten darüber keine
diskussion an leute spart euch wirklich
die zeit ein bekannter von mir war als
presse auf der fdp wahlparty und das war
nicht so schön die stimmung soll wie
sehr beängstigend gewesen sein obwohl
sie gefeuert haben kommen wir lieber zur
nächsten kategorie die viel schöner ist
wieder kind sein aus der aktuellen
situation heraus lasst uns wieder kind
sein und unsere menschen wieder mit
liebe begegnen und nicht mit vorurteilen
erinnert ihr euch noch daran wie er als
kind war hat man mit kindern gespielt
wie man sie nennt fan und habe nicht auf
irgendwelche herkunft oder statussymbole
oder sonstwas geachtet lasst uns alle
wieder lieb haben und gemeinsam dieser
hass welle bekämpfen und wenn das nicht
reicht und wieder kind zu sein dann
könnt ihr euch eine auswahl buch holen
und bilder ausmalen das habe ich
letztens ausgemalt und es hat super viel
spaß gemacht und ist noch dazu super
entspannt kommen wir nun zur twitter
frage ich hab euch gefragt wenn ihr dr
sommer zufällig auf der straße begegnet
was würdet ihr ihn frage ob man ihn auch
im winter fragen stehen man durchs
küssen schwanger werden ich hoffe du
fraktionen freund mein bauch umfang
wächst seit monaten bin ich schwanger
ist 69 eine alternative für zähneputzen
ist mit cola danach ausspülen auch ein
verhütungsmittel ob er doktor erkennt
wie bringe ich meinem freund bei dass
ich den mexikanischen wurst auch
praktizieren möchte hallo wie geht's
jetzt auch die lebensweise der woche wir
werden euch jagen mit liebe und das war
das letzte mal noch für dieses jahr ich
hoffe euch habe gefallen wenn ja dann
sex mit einem daumen nach oben und
schreibt mir etwas nennt es in die
kommentare
bitte nicht nur politisch ich weiß es
hat ein politisches thema dieses
sommerloch aber wir können jetzt auch
weiterleben und darauf schauen dass wir
uns alle
lieb haben und dass wir schauen dass wir
besser werden und uns mehr anstrengen um
mehr liebe zu verteilen liebe liebe
liebe und dann sehen wir uns bald wieder
hier sind video schaut ihr euch an oder
nicht
und ansonsten bis dann